what's up you chinchilla rellis we're
talking fatherhood this week females
with that loot step daddy etiquette we
got thick urine and depression on the
call sheet a little bit of follow up on
them female breadwinners and did you
know that I once slept in a McDonald's
ball pit yep when I first moved to Los
Angeles
overnight three nights in a row with an
Asian gentleman yep that I didn't even
know possibly Korean jury's still out
get up to get down bienvenidos este
scene they say mana this past weekend
[Applause]
[Music]
never places
Oliver a living there the fame is
[Music]
soon we're going to die let's have some
fun while we all die
that is the Spencer growl band and I'll
put a link to that on my YouTube where
you can catch that in full happy Monday
to you guys I'm happy to be here with
you guys it is Monday June 19th and it's
actually a birthdate of my grandmother
and my sister both of them are my
sister's alive and my grandmother is
dead she's gone
she loved raccoons and she collected a
lot of ceramic squirrels and ceramic
frogs and she was an older lady and
something happened to her and then she
died but I'm happy to be here with you
guys today I'm alive you're alive sorry
to start out on that dark note you know
but sometimes life can be a little bit
of a dark note we're going to keep it
happy today I appreciate you guys time
this is this past weekend and we are
here I had a wild dream last night and I
got some good rest this weekend because
I needed some rest
you know sometimes up I find myself
caught up in sleep you know and I'm just
like a little resting bear and I wish
sometimes that I kept a chart of when I
was resting you know throughout my
history and when I was awake because I
would have a better idea if I'm on some
sort of a resting cycle you know if I
hibernate a little bit more in in
certain times and I hit a bit of a rest
streak this weekend and caught me a rest
and I enjoyed it I actually had a wild
dream that I was a that I was mewling I
was a money mule and a money mule
you know mules are people that hide
stuff in there but or honest anus that
hide things inside of there between
their butt cheeks if the
really strong mules can these are humans
that hide stuff they can just grip it
between their butts and hold something
but if not then they have to put it
inside of their butts you know pass like
the entry area and that's very bizarre
and those are a lot of basic mules you
know and I'm kind of a weaker mule at
least I was in this dream and I was
hiding money
I was hiding money inside of my butt
rolls of coins and I had to basically
pay rent I was paying rent for a family
of illegal aliens this is a dream
sequence and I had to get into kind of
sneak into this area and sort of this is
going to sound wiry I guess but I had to
defecate into these big dumb banks and
then they had a man in there with a rake
and he was raking the money out raking
the rolls of coins out and helping this
family pay their rent so there was a lot
going on really I guess in my
subconscious well I just had to share
that with you guys happy Father's Day
happy belated Father's Day and we have a
lot of male listeners and a lot of good
men out there who are taking care of
children you know in some of these
children of yours and some of these
children are not there's some other
man's child and I want to give a round
of applause to those men right now and
commend you if you're a father and that
can come across a lot of ways to a child
you know it can come across where you
are just their their provider and you
might think that oh I'm just a provider
for this child if it's a stepchild you
know but that goes a long way and it may
take a while for that child to ret for
that to resonate with that child I mean
I remember a man took me in when I was
14 and he let me live with him and his
family and there was nothing sensual it
was all on the up-and-up and positive
and I was still a bad one you know wild
child but he provided a structure for me
and years later we are
we are great friends and I consider him
a great example in my life even though
at the time I didn't always recognize it
so I just want to come in the stepdads
out there who are doing that type of
behavior and who are you know providing
a comfortable atmosphere where a young
person can just feel comfortable enough
to learn about themselves because that's
huge because prior to that I didn't have
that in my own personal existence and I
know there's a lot of men out there
doing that because it's easy to be a
father I mean let's it's easy to create
a baby I mean if you just think of it's
just a bust of a nut I mean a small it's
just that moment between I'm going to
hold on to this nut and that moment
where I'm going to go in and bust this
nut and that that's the easy part
you know because any I mean you could
have a man with no legs out there and a
bad attitude
could still be busted knots everywhere
and making children you know it's a lot
of children that potentially could be
out there and that that immediately gets
you to dad's status you put that into an
ovary or throw that onto an egg of a
lady you're immediately at fatherhood
and that's wild you know to think that
there's not more of a a law against nut
use is pretty baffling to me you know I
almost felt like and I talked about this
in my Netflix special at the end where
they should almost take a child's nuts
off of them you know they circumcised
children I think they take the wrong
part they're taking all this extra skin
they're taking all this extra detect you
know this extra epidermis around the the
[ __ ] top and they're you know that
turtleneck because your penis will start
turtleneck and around the top if you are
natural and they cut that off but I
think they should take the nuts give
them back to you once you have a degree
once you have graduated school you know
once you have done something to deserve
the ability to create another because
we're just letting any will
nilly or any nilly willy really run
around with active skeet and that to me
I don't I don't think that that's
behaving us anymore I think that you're
nuts and your ability to you know spray
out a family should be something you
earn an achievement you know and that's
a way that I would like to see us evolve
biologically I got me some coffee here
guys but can you imagine if all of our
seed grew up I mean I personally you
know myself have probably I'm trying to
think if I've been masturbating for I'm
37 I've been masturbating for probably
25 years safely and I would say 300
that's 300 sprays a year probably safely
that's I mean that is that's that's 7500
sprays and if all of that grew up and
that's just me alone that's 7,500
children you know that could potentially
be out there so I'm amazed that we don't
get a handle on more of this human seed
and then it's not more of a that it's
that it's not more of a prized
possession you know because we're
spraying it out like it's nothing I mean
it's like I mean we're giving it away a
lot of men are so I think it's
commendable to when a man actually has a
child gets it to you know full creation
and then cares about it and builds it up
and if you're a man out there who has a
child that they're not you know they're
not in touch with right now because that
kid is in their teens or late teens or
something sometimes I think it's
probably just about patience you know if
I could dig back into my childhood and
think think about a father figure or
parents sometimes you just need that you
just it's just patience so I commend you
men that are out there fathering
children raising children steppe
fathering I mean stepfather is a very
underestimated occupation very
undervalued in America you know I mean
anybody really can can create a child
you know some Oh spring but to get out
there and take care
someone else's child just because you
solely know that that kid needs it
that's beautiful and I commend you men
that do that it's a beautiful thing man
and stepfather you know usually they
have a mustache you know they want to
grow that hair out above their lip and I
respect that too that's a beautiful
thing people ask me a lot why you
growing your hair out because I got this
beautiful I mean and I said not even
growing that God is growing this the
Lord is growing this beauty off the back
of my skull I'm just a sharecropper you
know I'm out here farming I'm out here
tending to the crop and that's what I do
and people say well it looks nice and I
said well I'm a good farmer that's what
I tell them because I believe that but
happy Father's Day I hope everyone had a
good Father's Day if they did have one
and that you were able to reach out to
your father to your or your children
reached out to you and and express their
care concern you know and if you got a
kid to that's really young I also want
to say I know it's tricky to spank them
now or to beat them you know but you
know throw it on them every now and then
something light a reminder even if you
just have to play an old video of the
past you know play some Beatles or
something beat them lightly something
just reminds them who's in control
because every man you know I think if
they can live if they can live and get
too comfortable feeling they can create
a family and it's got to be pretty
beautiful to do all that you know so I
commend you fathers out there and I hope
you live long and prosperous lives we
shall see we shall see what else did I
want to tell you guys about that I
wanted to thought about fatherhood you
know I mean my father was so old put a
picture of him up on my Instagram and
that's just Theo von if you want to
check it out of when I was a baby of you
know an inkling a tall sperm if you will
even and um and and my father was in his
young 70s at that point and we didn't do
too much I remember playing on his
Walker in our yard and and just remember
his breath smelled like beer and that he
had a lot of change in his pockets I
would
jingle often and he whistled a lot and
it's little things like that that I
really treasure and value when I think
I'm my own personal father I want to
tell you guys I know I've been thinking
about the patreon or patreon I've been
talking about it I'd love to know your
thoughts on it I'm a little to be honest
I'll be you know just 100% transparent
I'm a little nervous about putting it
out there and just having it be this
thing where you know where I feel like
there's an extra pressure to create
something every month but there's not
that many people that are interested in
supporting it because it's not something
you guys should have to take on either
but I'd love to just know your thoughts
on patreon or patreon if you've done it
with other with other podcasts and how
you feel about it you know and just be
honest with me put your two cents out
there you can put it in the YouTube
comments as well if you're listening on
iTunes
go ahead and subscribe drop a comment or
rating something tell your friends about
the podcast so we can keep it going and
we can keep the excitement building and
and I'm grateful to you guys I've some
dates coming up I'm going to tell you
right now I will be in New York City
this weekend Friday and Saturday night
at Gotham comedy club Thursday I got a
surprise show I'm doing with the Chive
and that's a website that's about you
know they talk about titties and humor
basically titties and humor and
beautiful God some of the nipples on
that site huh well just lead me straight
to a dirty place on the Internet but
they have that I'll be working with them
and that's that stand-up live this
Thursday in Phoenix what else after that
I'll be in Nashville coming up I'll be
in Stark County Illinois coming up I've
got dates also in Cleveland those are on
the website now you can check those out
where else any world super exciting
Vegas and The Improv in Addison Texas
Austin and Brea improv that's all later
this year you can get those dates at
Theo von comm slash tour slash tour but
yeah hope everybody had a good Father's
Day my weekend was pretty calm when I
think about this past weekend it was
pretty calm I spent some time with Simon
Rex some of you guys know him Dirt Nasty
that
white rapper and he's got a new series
called typical Rick with him in Nick
Swardson and man Nick makes me laugh man
and their series makes me laugh if you
haven't seen typical Rick go check it
out those guys do a really good job
that's on Comedy Central Digital and you
can check that out right there but let
me know what you think of patreon or
patreon so many of your thoughts I want
to know I want to know what you're
thinking I'm gonna get quickly into some
questions here we had a lot of people
hit the hotline with some comments some
thoughts and that number if you don't
have it yet I'm going to tell it to you
right now is nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
hit the hotline let me know what your
struggles are your thoughts your
feelings put something out there put
something out there we can work with
together so we can keep the good the
good vibe that's going on here going on
here we're getting late in June you know
a lot going on summer solstices this
week so that means it will be the
longest day of the year so spend time
with people that you care about you know
because it's going to be a long day just
make sure you plan ahead a little bit a
lot of sunlight so it's a good day to
get your work done and maybe catch a
sunset or do something special with
somebody that you enjoy I'm going to tap
into some of these calls people hit the
hotline and you can text the hotline as
well you can just text it you can text
an issue in if you have it and I'm going
to tap into one right now this one is
from Columbia South Carolina and I used
to go to college over there in South
Carolina and a few some you guys know
that or not at the College of Charleston
heavily enjoyed myself over there a lot
of ghosts in that area too if you like
ghosts or the dead there's a lot of them
there and they're milling around but
this is a Riley from Columbia South
Carolina love your podcast you make
people laugh and sorry love your podcast
you make people laugh and that is a gift
from the universe I have a great woman
this gentleman is telling me and
relationship
but in the past I've struggled with the
thought of marriage and being fully
committed to another human I come from a
family where divorce is everywhere what
are your thoughts on commitment and ways
to stay focused in a committed
relationship I'm glad you asked this
Riley I really am
because I'm going to just drop my
feelings one commitment scares me
brother you know it scares me I've
always been scared of it in a
relationship it scares me
now if I think about having children and
being committed to those children and
making sure they're clean and their
hearts are good I feel like I have that
in me you know I would be committed to
my children and why I guess but I'll be
committed to them just because I just
don't question it it's not a question
you know but when it comes to commitment
to a woman you know I guess the first
thing it hits me is that it's growing up
and part of me just doesn't want to do
that sometimes I have this issue with it
you know I feel like I'm because
commitment you're you feel like as a man
I feel like any way that I'm heading
towards marriage or towards a family and
a lot of times when when you don't feel
like your own childhood this is real to
me that if that I don't feel like my own
childhood was complete you know and I
hated my childhood to be honest with you
you know we had some exciting moments
that I'm able to reflect on now and look
back on but I hated being a kid it was
uncomfortable it was I didn't have I
didn't have any a lot of influences that
made me feel good and so by committing
now in your relationship I feel like my
childhood would be ending you know I
feel like my childhood would be you know
it would be over if I commit now that
I'm adulting so much that my ability to
even you know to complete that childhood
is gone
whatever whatever I still needed to do
even if I'm not doing anything that that
my ability to to continue to work on
that childhood or to have a good
childhood is over so that's I guess kind
of a scary feeling that troubles me with
commitment you know because I know that
once I get locked into a lady that my
youth is over you know at that point and
I think that that's one of the reasons
why I personally Riley have trouble with
commitment because I just feel that
heavy pressure that our man your youth
is done man your childhood is done
whatever you felt like or uneven about
or things you were holding on that's all
has to go away now because now you're
going to be headed towards focusing on
somebody else
and that's something that really that
really scares me I think that's one of
the biggest reasons that I have
commitment issues you know let me think
a second reason is probably cuz I'm
afraid not to do something alone most of
my life I've done things by myself you
know I don't know I think I got used to
being by myself when I was young used to
completing tasks by myself or even not
completing them at least then there was
no other responsibility you know to
another person it will it all rested on
me and I feel like by by joining up with
somebody that that's going to stop you
know commitment means and I'm not doing
this alone anymore and sometimes I feel
like I've been alone so long in my own
mind and heart that I don't want to
admit that that I need somebody else or
that I would be better off with someone
else and by getting into a committed
relationship for me I guess part of me
feels like I'd be doing that I'd be
admitting that that that I'm not good
enough alone and also I struggle with
feeling that need I struggle with
feeling the real need to have someone
else around because I I just wasn't used
to it you know I haven't been used to
it's gotten better as I've gotten older
here recently but it's tough for me to
feel that need
it's tough for me to feel it I can say
it I can think it but to really feel it
because I think I've suppressed that in
that that's so long to need someone else
that it's not a comfortable feeling for
me so that'll probably take some work in
that area for me personally to feel
those things and that self and that's
self work that I need that I need to get
into you know because that's important
stuff because that's you know without
some commitment at some point that I'm
going to be alone and I can tell you
that that figuring out why you feel that
way is probably pretty freeing you know
because where I found myself today is
not knowing why I feel why I feel the
ways that I feel and that's scary man
you know what I don't know why I feel a
certain way like I can feel it but I
just don't know why I can't it doesn't
resonate to my brain very well and and
that's scary because then the issue is
that I just can't understand my feelings
I'm not good at understanding my own
feelings that's kind of scary at my age
and it's scary to think that I've put
off for a long time you know getting
some help in those areas so that I can
understand some of those feelings you
know for someone to be like well why do
you feel like that and for me to be so
out of touch with my feelings that I
don't know the answer I mean it's it's
not cool anymore you know I think for a
long time it was cool but it's tough to
admit that it's just not cool anymore
it's not cool for me at my age to still
be in that environment and the third
reason I'll say Riley is commitment for
me is since I always felt like I took
care of myself emotionally and then I
never got any reward for that you know
even though there were other people that
helped me and that raised me for some
reason in in my mind and heart there was
always this feeling that I was doing it
all by myself you know I think just some
of that loneliness I felt inside just
that's how it manifested itself and
there's probably a lot of truth you know
most of my youth felt more like
surviving than it did living or thriving
so the fact that I never felt any reward
for that it made me it makes me want to
hold on to my loneliness or my
singularity a little bit out of spite
if that makes any sense you know now
spite against whom I don't know that's
the thing it's like I'm just holding the
spite but there's no one really that I'm
holding it against because the only
person that suffering by me having this
anger is me at this point you know so
I'm glad you asked this man because it's
something that I've been thinking about
a lot because I have trouble getting
close to other people and and I think
those are some of the reasons why you
know I don't know if any of that helps
or any that answers some of your
question but I do appreciate you you
know you reaching out and asking about
commitment because it helps me to be
able to think of some of my thoughts and
I'd love to know some of you men are
struggling with commitment out there you
know we're ladies I go I've had some
calls from some ladies I think men might
be shot a call but we're not perfect
creatures and one thing about the times
we're in right now I think it's almost a
blessing in a way where there's so many
blurred lines and we've talked about
this a little bit and females being the
breadwinners and it's kind of a unique
time for men to be able to share their
feelings you know that some of some of
those stuff sounds gay as hell you know
and that sort of thing you can say that
but but dude it's better than running
around and not knowing what your
feelings are that's where I've spent a
lot of my life and it's one of the
reasons why like having this past
weekend because some of us are able to
to to call and share questions and
thoughts and concerns on all of this man
because I get a lot of calls to that
aren't people that have questions that
just want to say something and just want
to share and I'm grateful for those also
let's take another caller man this is
Chris from Las Vegas I believe and he's
just texting in this is another text
when I'll just read this one I know this
is Chris from Utah do I love the show I
just wanted to get your advice
on kind of a weird fear or phobia that I
have of homeless people like I try to
help out in kitchens I'm guessing he's
saying homeless kitchens and serving
places like that soup and you know light
fair chowder actually probably heavy
fare Meat Loaf's but but if I walk by
the homeless in downtown Salt Lake City
I get really nervous I don't know why I
think maybe they might rob me or stab me
or something
just wondering if you've been able to
get past some kind of phobia it's a good
question you know when I was young had
this heavy phobia of the dark very
scared of the dark and of going to sleep
at night and I've said before I thought
animals were going to get me I used to
urinate in a circle around my bed I used
to push my bed off the wall and then I
would urinate in a big circle because I
had heard somewhere that animals
wouldn't go where there was other
animals urine and I knew I wasn't an
animal but I just thought in my young
brain that they would you know get my
scent and be scared crows I was also
very scared of crows I remember putting
a lot of yarn up in the air with jingle
bells on them on the arm you know on the
thread and thinking of a crow would hit
that they came in and get me I would lay
down at night I've talked about this on
stage and put jingle bells on top of my
blanket or set them on my clavicles or
where there was a place in my chest or
something could hold them and I would
fall asleep like that real still and
hope that they would wake me up if they
went off if something happened I
remember having to look through every
nook and cranny at every angle I just
start in the closets and work my way out
and then lean something against one
closet door and then do the other closet
door just to make sure there was nothing
around so I had a heavy fear growing up
you know a lot of fear there are a lot
of bedwetting and I don't have any shame
for it I mean it's I think I did for a
long time but now I'm just like you know
I'm just I feel pretty fortunate that I
made it through it feel some of those
things you know but as far as the
homeless go
you know I say trust your instincts
that's what I usually do with the
homeless you know because I don't
recommend engaging with the homeless
there's there are people out there who
are social workers who this is their job
that is their life desire if you feel
that then yes that's amazing go get it
done
but if you're just walking down the
street and it's 11 p.m. and suddenly you
got this thing where you think you're a
social worker I back off that instinct
because that's probably incorrect
because also do you think that the
homeless want to scare people have
scared people that's helping them you
know do you think the homeless want some
easily spooked MOOC you know spooning
out their precious soup you know who you
know one wrong sound and the distance is
going to you know freak out and sling
chowder all over everybody no probably
not
so by being so scared and odd you're
probably really spooking them and the
homeless I'll say probably Chris from
Utah they're not for you and that's
another thing we got to realize
sometimes it does make you a bad person
if you're not overly helping the
homeless not everyone is for everyone
you know I see Orthodox Jewish people in
LA they take no interest in me and I'm
like you know what do we have anything
in common maybe a little bit of religion
but outside of that no I don't engage so
I don't engage you know I see two dogs
attacking a man you know the man looks
like he's going to survive what am I
going to do if I show up you know so
sometimes it's just about realizing that
a situation isn't for you that there's
somebody better fit for that because
I've seen two to two dogs fighting a man
in a park and that's not my [ __ ] man
that's not my [ __ ] you know I'm just not
about that world you know I don't know
what am I gonna do karate no so I'm out
so you got to know where to engage man
you know I think you
you know stand tall and be proud and be
affectionate if you feel that there
needs to be that affection if there's an
opportunity for you to share some money
some water some food do that but don't
mill around skating around boo radley
and around the concrete you're going to
scare the homeless you know but not
everyone is for everyone you know like
if I see an angry feminist you know
who's you know making flammable [ __ ] or
something in her parents basement you
know which are probably hard-working
mustache stepfather and mother probably
busting their asses to put a roof over
her head
I don't intervene in that you know
there's nothing that I'm going to be I
it's just not everything's for everyone
what am I going to say to this girl
nothing she's angry at man right now at
this point I'm not saying that's every
feminist or every you know Pro womanhood
person but I mean they got some wild
cats out there and I'll tell you this
couple of facts about the homeless if
you want to get upset about the
condition of the homeless throw some
darts at a Ronald Reagan poster okay
because that beautifully quaff Ronald
Reagan was the original Donald Trump man
look it up and I loved Ronald Reagan I
was a Reaganite you know he's a kind of
a political Michael Landon you know
there's a there's a story out there in
on the Internet where because Ronald
Reagan was an actor and there was a
story in the Internet where he allegedly
when he won the presidency he said he
only wanted to do president about five
hours a day that he was he's going to do
other stuff in the evening and he would
shut down at 6:30 p.m. I believe or 7:30
p.m. you can look this up and I don't
know if this is fake news because I
don't know what's real out there anymore
but he would shut it down in him and
sweet Nancy had that piece as his lady
would watch television and enjoy their
lives a little bit and I like that
that's one of the things I loved about
Ronald Reagan you know and he's beloved
by millions billions maybe but I'll say
this sweet Ronnie put the homeless he
shut down a lot of the mental health
centers
so you used to just have the homeless
who were dope heads and hippies and lazy
people and people who you know we're
counting pennies instead of counting
cash because you count pennies long
enough you'll just be out there counting
them you know you that's all you'll have
but look it up Ronald Reagan let him
loose he cut the budget for a lot of
mental health and next thing you know
you had a dude out there who was just
shooting up you know who would busting a
couple you know cubes or crank into his
nose and then you had a dude out there
who had no clue who he was who was
mentally unhealthy schizophrenic you
know there's a you know there's actually
there's a University of Pennsylvania
study let me find this right here I put
this down of 5,000 homeless people in
New York City found this study found
that they cost the public forty thousand
five hundred dollars annually on average
per person that's crazy and that's
comprised of prison shelter emergency
room and psychiatric hospital costs you
think there would be a better way to
just get those people this forty
thousand five hundred dollars because if
we get it directly to them maybe it
would change their element you know and
that was what makes you realize that a
lot of it is mental health out there you
know that's a lot of mental health going
on out there and that's where it's scary
so if you're feeling uncomfortable about
engaging you know they say only about
thirty percent of the people out there
are drug addicts alcoholics and drug
addicts you know so it's tough to know
when to engage I would just say trust
your instincts Chris I mean I feel
uncomfortable around the home is the
homeless you know first of all there's a
million ways to keep a home I mean we
got two story homes we've got what else
mobile homes means you can if you're
almost homeless you can take your home
with you come on home let's go I got to
go let's go you know so I feel wiry
around them there's a lot of them out
here in Los Angeles and I feel a little
troubled at times and uncertain you know
and I feel gross sometimes I feel
compassionate I feel compassionate more
than I used to I feel angry though
when it's the middle of the day you've
got a schizophrenic guy stuck in the
crosswalk
because there's something blinking at
him tell him to go this way or tell them
to go that way you know I feel like
there should be a little bit Morgan
ization you know also feel upset in LA
like a stray animal you see you see a
stray Bichon on the street you see a
stray weiner dog that little [ __ ]
going to be he'll be at a spa in an hour
okay he'll have a key level special
college fund put away for him people
help them you see a stray Daniel a stray
Larry nobody never gets picked up man no
bathe so it's wild man it's something
it's wild they said there's an old thing
that says like you're only as good as
your common lowest common denominator
and how you treat your poorest in your
and your troubled and it's it's hectic
man I went to an AAA meeting at the VA
yesterday the Veterans Administration
and it's wild to see those guys on what
they're going through you know and I am
hopeful that you know some of this new
administration will help take care of
some of those guys whatever else they're
doing I've never trusted the politicians
any of them I always thought they were
louts up to no good
you know we're men who have served our
country whether for whatever reason they
served whether it was a criminal
sentence or whatever you know they have
skin in the game and I feel like we
should try and help take care of that
skin but then it's also tough because
you got people to start to live off the
system you know there's always two sides
but but yeah it's tough dealing with the
homeless man it's tough it's tough
dealing with the homeless the only way
to overcome that fear is probably to
interact with them and then develop a
gauge as to where your interaction with
the homeless is you know I mean dance
with the devil dance with the devil and
you'll learn how to two-step you know in
Satan's atmosphere and that's the truth
man wouldn't be here here would be a
cool new show it's almost a fear factor
type of show sleep wouldn't spoon a
homeless person for a night you know
would you let a real homeless dude spoon
you all
you're the little spoon okay you're the
shrimp spoon or whatever the caviar
spoon am at would you get any rest I
think we learn a lot about ourselves you
know our souls right then you know that
do could be laying back behind you
eating your hair you know contemplating
murder you know trying to smell your
blood type through your scalp this guy
could be doing anything so that's you
know that might be a unique show because
you'd learn a lot about yourself you'd
be able to gauge really quickly where
you stand with the homeless in your
comfort level but it'd be a great way to
overcome your fear of homelessness if
you do do that mr.christopher please
send us in a picture or a video of you
out there spending time with your new
friend but yeah there's a lot of
homeless man you know and they're
probably scared of us too you have to
think about that it's very I mean
they're human raccoons a lot of them and
I'm not saying that to make fun of them
but they're they're they are more nature
than they are man at certain point you
can see it in their eyes sometimes you
walk up on a homeless guy you feel like
you're walking up on a raccoon try it
go surprised a couple raccoons by the
trash now then go surprised a couple
homeless guys outside of a trash area or
a 7-elevens write down the notes take
notes and see their uniqueness man but
what I do is I try to offer a basic food
a basic water a dollar couple of dollars
five if it's a woman sometimes because I
know that they need extra products and
stuff and I go on about my way you know
and I try to help someone who's maybe a
little bit closer to me who's a little
bit more in a comfortable range to be
helped at this time you know because you
have to be able to help somebody who can
also help themselves at times you know
but they shut down those mental health
centers a long time ago and yet homeless
people out on the street that's another
thing if I see homeless people making
out I will call the police I've done it
countless times and in New Orleans I see
a couple of homeless people out there
lip-locking you know touching pant tops
you know around the crotch area you know
being luscious you know
pressing their palms up against each
other's crotch or you know nervous nerve
endings trying to get at each other's
nerve endings around the crotch at the
top of the legs because to homeless
people making love that makes a little
homeless person immediately and I told
this officer one time on the phone of
the dispatcher she's giving me all this
lip about this and that I'm like lady do
you realize they have a child that that
child is immediately homeless so that's
something I think where you want to get
the the authorities engaged you know but
yeah but they're wild man a lot of
homeless are like insects too and I'll
say that I don't mean that in a bad way
but they are they're like it's almost a
we have that relationship that we do
with insects some will sting you some
will suck your blood you know some of
them flock to garbage or flock to you
know you know flock to Sun lighter to a
lantern if you leave a lantern on I
remember when I lived in Charleston we
leave the porch light on and in the
morning there'd be a couple of homeless
people out there some of them are
beautiful made us land on your sleeve
like a butterfly so there really it's
you're dealing with nature a lot of
times you know some of them will lay
eggs in the garbage you know we're on a
you know someone will lay eggs in your
and your grandmother's scalp you know I
mean there's you get the wild ones you
know you got a lot going on but I'm
fascinated about how we relate to them I
really am because it's very unique I
mean I remember when I first moved out
here in Los Angeles I was used to
sleeping the Macdonald ball pit and I've
said mentioned this story before my
buddy and I were looking for an
apartment
and I would jump over at night we didn't
have a place to stay we would jump over
the defense at the McDonald's after
midnight and we would sleep bare in the
ball pit and it's nasty a lot of hair
dirt they don't vacuum the bottom of
them they didn't used to this was 12
years ago my friend Paul we were just
friends nothing sensual and we'd get in
there and rest at night the third night
we get in there
we're chatting and cutting up and you
know not doing any jerking off because
that all if there's somebody else around
immediately you don't do it really
because there's some shame there if you
notice that sometimes you don't do it
only because you don't want that shame
but the third night we're in there
clowning around and they you hear all of
a sudden you hear and you guys have
quieted down
Melissa turn is Lee boo and there was a
Korean man I believe Korean it's hard to
understand Korean at night but there was
a Korean man sleeping on the slide in
there so we weren't even the first
people to have this idea but but I
thought that was interesting that people
were using this place as a nighttime
facility to rest and the reason I
thought of it was because when I was
young my sister was very ill when I was
young she had a rare liver disease that
affects about one and maybe half a
million children where she was born and
needed a liver transplant and I remember
the Ronald McDonald House was a special
place where they would let parents come
stay who didn't have any money so they
could spend time around their sick
children while the children were under
the care of the hospital facility and my
sister went there and my mother would go
stay in the different cities at the
Ronald McDonald House while she was on
these tours to visit the doctors and
that resonated in me and I was like Oh
Ronald McDonald won't care if we catch a
night's rest and that's how we ended up
there another interaction with the
homeless that I've had was why was it
doing a show at Loyola Marymount this is
about eight years ago nine years ago
maybe and it was myself and a friend I
may have told this story before my
memory is very short and they I was
judging like an American Idol type of
contest they had on their campus and had
about maybe eight hundred students that
were in attendance and at the last
minute they called and said can you
bring a couple of friends who were
judges who can be judges myself and a
friend of mine were the emcees of the
event and we needed judges so I hit the
park near me and
quickly interviewed a couple of the
homeless or without homes sans Casas and
got two gentlemen rich one of his name
was rich the irony they are a little but
man I can't remove the other guy's name
rich and we brought them with us and we
sat them in the judges chairs curtains
open and next thing you know these two
men who were laying in a park an hour
earlier we're at a $40,000 a year
University judging the students ability
to entertain and when we got to the end
there was a moment we had a tally up the
scores right so we're sitting there
discussing the scores with him we got
the scores we had a few more minutes and
one of the guys said I don't think it
was rich it was the other guy he was
more of a blonde rich was a brunette and
he said can I perform something and he
got out there with a with a guitar that
some other student had used to perform
and he played a song and he made up
about Jack Daniels and it was beautiful
man beautiful song got really violent at
the end with some broken glass and stuff
and but the audience went crazy man they
cheered for him and I thought that was a
beautiful moment of how a homeless
person can you know a lot of us the
environment you're in you know it's just
you just need to be put into an
environment for success that's what that
showed me and that goes right back to
you know why I commend a lot of fathers
and stepfathers out there whose children
can be angry troubled violent whatever
all it takes is at one moment where this
the environment for success that you've
provided by providing them meals a
little bit of money some structure all
it takes that one moment for them to see
that perspective or to feel comfortable
for them to begin to shine and really
grasp on to who they are and to really
start to light up the world with some
skills or talents that they have so
again I commend commend our fathers and
stepfathers out there all right guys
let's go to some actual calls I know
we're call heavy this week I was going
to do a follow-up last week about
addiction but I didn't you know I'm
going through voicemails I didn't have a
lot of calls about people that had
struggled
with it I thought I'd had more I'd
addressed some of them and when I get a
build up of my will I will address those
thank you for anybody who's called in
about that again the hotline that men or
women can hit that number is nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
I appreciate that call about the
homeless and how we relate to them I
remember we used to go in the park and
do fun games for people with homes and
people without homes
anybody can compete against anyone it
was a show we were pitching called
street games about ten years ago and
I'll put one up this weekend on the
youtubes and we used to have we have
some a homeless guy doing cartwheels in
a yogurt contest doing yogurt so really
beautiful but let's take another call
here we got a color and this guy's
actually from Louisiana let's see what's
going on here onward CEO Michael from
Baton Rouge Michael from Baton Rouge
thank you for calling man my family's
all down there and I'm happy to have you
call today on we're here Michael show
following up with an inquiry so I know
you talked a lot about laying off of the
drink in the master baton and the
pornography myself I've been able to
with you as an inspiration to lay off of
the drinkin for two weeks and the
masturbating pornography for at least
one of those weeks my question is two
weeks that's huge man I'm just going to
say that because that shows that you
have some control over it you know and I
just want you I want you guys to
remember that if you're struggling with
addiction is struggling with knowing
where you fit in those things it is a
questionnaire you can find out there
that will help you figure out if you
suffer from alcoholism and I'm not
accusing you Michael I'm just saying
that you know that's inspiring you
you're able to set parameters for
yourself and follow those and live up to
those but I'll let's hear your inquiry
here on we've been drinking a lot of
water even healthy and having these
thick story and pleasurable pisses is
that okay as a 27 year old male with
with a cutting out alcohol and
masturbating gab these pleasurable
six-string pisses advise me
so please
let me know we'll see you in addison
because I live out here in Dallas so see
you at the improv
vo oh right on brother thank you I'm
excited to see you man so you're having
sick stream urine you know and urine I'm
going to say it right now it's a
byproduct of being human we know that
right other things have other byproducts
are car leaks gasoline sometimes it can
leak it can leak water it can leak you
know all antifreeze fluid you know the
Sun leaked heat you know we leak urine
that's a byproduct and is it you know
your cut oh Christ sorry you're cutting
off of um you know you're cutting off of
alcohol and you're eating healthy and
you're having thicker urine I think
that's fine man you know I grew up
around a boy who would piss thick and
this fella could I mean thick thick did
I mean almost like uh you know like he
was a like a pastry chef or something
you know do with that little frosting
gun you know I mean this guy had of just
really was you know just spouting hot
cream almost and he might have had an
infection he was too young for a sexual
affection infection but but you know I'm
no doctor and I was young but he he what
he wasn't very bright and I and I bet he
was he was probably dangerous things
that he probably wasn't even supposed to
be you know things that you know were
just just ignorant snacks you know but I
remember one time we got a sheet it was
so interesting to us we got a sheet and
held it out me and my boy Danny who was
born with the deficiency had a very he
had a soft neck a very limp neck but we
would hold this bedsheet out and we had
this boy piss out into it and the the
end of the stretched bed sheet and the
sheet almost caught this I don't want to
say it was like a butter but it was like
a like a meringue almost that was left
by this boy's your
and I thought that at the time we're not
dating I was a little scared for him you
know but he didn't look sick
his eyes were clear you know I just
thought you know maybe he just shouldn't
be eaten certain things and he was
eating them you know and I don't know if
in the future maybe we will be able to
actually piss a product that we can use
this actually makes me think about the
future you know if if in the future
there Michael you might even you might
be on to something because what if in
the future we could feed you six eggs
you know four limes a couple lemons
maybe some vanilla extract and we could
get you to you know make a topping for a
pet it for a couple petit fours or a
couple of you know pineapple cakes and
you could urinate something that's
useful you know that might be something
that the future holds biologically for a
lot of humans you know is a an edible
by-product because it really almost is
ridiculous
that we've had our digestive tracts for
this long in history we have this much
medical advancement we can put a heart
into somebody else you know we can get
my sister a new liver you know she got
it when she was 14 years old out of
there at University of Arizona Hospital
they were one of the first places to do
it she was like one of the first 20
people to get it especially a child but
to think that net we're not even using
our own digestive tracts as a as aa as a
kitchen of sorts you know that's
interesting ma'am I mean if you feel
comfortable and you're fun you're
probably fine I mean this boy but he did
this boy I remember his name Ravus maybe
Ravus kind of Travis but without the tea
and Ravus would piss this it was a
meringue almost and we didn't need it
but it looked merengue you know but I
think you'll be neat if in the future
you know somebody can buy some salmon
and then next thing you know you know
some rest
ppit's or shows up and just drops a
beautiful demi-glaze on it
they solely on whatever that person had
eaten in that day you know and I think
that that's spectacular to think about
you know and I'm thinking you you'll
probably face an issue if you if it gets
too thick it's probably not going to
come out you know and at that point
you're going to be that's going to be
troublesome because I've heard of people
trying to pass a stone I've never heard
of somebody kind of pass you know a damn
quarter frosting so I don't know what
the pain level could be there but but
good luck with that man I appreciate you
calling about it and good luck to
getting back to a decent stream or you
know at least evolving into a quality
stream that's of use but I appreciate
that man all right let's crack into one
more call here here we go let's hit this
right here we've been talking about a
lot female breadwinners and a lot of men
and called dance and their wives were
the breadwinners and helping us get into
that world and it's a lot going on
because you cannot feel like a man you
cannot feel like a man and it's
something that a lot of people like well
this isn't really going to happen and
it's just it's just happening
statistically and that's fine if you
feel that way it's fine if I feel that
way but the reality is that a lot of
children are growing up in homes where
the mother is the breadwinner a lot of
our friends our confidants a lot of
fellow men out there and women and
lesbian women and Hardy women strong you
know virile women who just want to just
stretch their vagina out into a [ __ ] and
just live hard they these people are no
longer the breadwinners so it's it's a
real thing for some people and I had
some calls about that let's hit this one
right here a field house is calling
about yeah the whole thing and that are
women kind of taking control of the
household and I'm in this it's racing
right now
all right this gentleman said he's in
that situation right now his woman is
taking control of the
household and I am Mardis he's an artist
she said I could mean anything but we're
going to take his word for it on murder
I enjoyed my time take care of little
guys house great the only God change is
the young since I came to provide for
family it's hard to deal with at first I
had previous previous problems of
children truth about 15 years and I had
an off that for about a year but when I
got shot in this situation where I got a
DUI
okay so he'd been he had an addiction
problems sharing up for about 15 years
and I appreciate you sharing that with
me but blood openly thank you for
sharing that he had those problems you
then he got into this situation he was
clean he got into this situation where
he was not the breadwinner where this
woman was and it sounds like he had a
relapse of sorts onwards oh lady took
control of the whole situation for me
just kind of helped and it were in the
best place we are now young leader than
so you know adult hands are the devil's
playground he said I don't hands are the
devil's playground now I know this cause
a little tough to hear sorry about that
idle hands are the devil's playground
it's very true and it sounds like maybe
at first when he got into the home with
the wife and she was making the loot
that he had these idle hands onward so
try not to sit around Tremont you do
wrong I'm doing something I'm doing good
now it's working out great as far as my
situation right now we got a little guys
four years old taking over the daddy
control who's his father captain Andy's
one and just been doing it and it's been
an experience that I loved every moment
of it I'm not you give me a little
insight what you feel as far if you were
putting us at risk awesome and I
appreciate sharing that it warms my
heart man to know that there's a you
know that there was a one-year-old whose
father passed away and you took over he
and it warms my heart to know that
you're out there being open about your
struggles man because I just the shame
of having struggles and being unable to
share them there's something unnecessary
there you know and maybe we live in a
world that judges too much and that but
if we can't find we if we can't look at
each other and know what each other is
going through man we're gonna have a
really tough time relating to each other
I feel so I really appreciate you
sharing that I commend you man happy
Father's Day to you you know I don't
know if your four-year-old on if it's
four or five you said the little guy
there now but it sounds like he's going
to grow up with an opportunity to have a
two-parent home there and that's
beautiful man that that warms my heart
man so thank you for sharing I was going
to answer some of your question but
there's a lot of stuff I can't relate to
there but I feel pretty fortunate this
week I got another call from a
househusband I'll call this gentleman
Nutt and I'm just I'm gonna call it that
and he's going to answer it for you so I
could throw you some guidance I can
throw some some thought some basic life
suggestions I just commend you for being
a good father man for picking up the
slack where fate you know drop the ball
by taking that other by taking that
child's biological father I really
commend you man that's a beautiful thing
I want to have your question answered I
think this guy's call answered it up for
me a little bit better than I could so
let's play that here here we go hey Theo
this is Billy out in California my
wife's been a breadwinner for 16 years
and I thought I could give you a little
insight from behind the lines on that
behind enemy lines there huh his wife
has been a breadwinner for 16 years as
Billy in California onward when I met
her I was a blue-collar guy
former Navy Seabee always a construction
always a hands-on type you and uh she
was in college she was a starving
college student the typical eating ramen
noodles and all that stuff and I should
pay for everything and
take her out to nice places and pay her
bills and all that stuff but okay so you
put in some work there it sounds like
you know by being the fiscal half
continue please but when she graduated
she became a naval officer and
everything switched almost immediately
so it's a real blow to your ego because
you know I'm an independent person I
don't like relying on anybody but over
the years I've learned that the way to
deal with the best you know you just got
to own it man you know I'm not a house
husband I'm a trophy husband and uh you
know you got to up your man game you got
to take the traditional values of men 50
years ago and apply it to your house and
apply to your marriage because believe
it or not you know career women don't
want a wife they don't want you know a
house [ __ ] you know they want a man
dang you heard him right there they
don't want a house [ __ ] you know I'm a
trophy husband you got to embrace it
that's what he's saying and I love that
man
and I know that that first call you're
asking for my suggestions what I would
do in that place I would hope that I
would have the attitude of this
gentleman here the second caller about
this topic I would hope that I would
have this attitude you know and because
I didn't really have an answer but this
is why we get my answer from somebody
else somebody who knows onward only hear
more and they're not trying to be men
they want to be treated like ladies and
uh maybe even more so because they're
you know dealing with that role every
day so you know my advice if anybody's
going to go through this is you know
just own it and after game man you know
be that be the man that your dad was 60
years ago - the job you know fix the
cars well how to fix the house the sink
you know Bend your wife over the sink
every once in a while she likes that
kind of stuff
dang dude doing some plumbing huh a
little bit of roto-rooter activity right
there boy yeah man people's eatin ass
out there buddy our sinks and everything
and he's celebrating out there but I
like it you know this gentleman you can
hear in his voice he's got that bravado
about being a man still you know you
don't have to not be a man just because
the income is coming from somewhere else
that we still have a responsibility this
is what I needed to hear man this is
awesome let's continue on a little more
here you know treat her like a lady but
you sit at the head of the table you
tell the kids you know you know when you
have kids it's important you got to be a
dad you can't just be you know want to
mom's just because you're not bringing
in all the bacon you can still sit at
the head of that table lead prayer you
know be the man that's what women want
and uh you know if you find yourself in
this situation
you know it's going to [ __ ] with you
it's going to make your ego you know
you're gonna get the press about it but
you know just own it and you know it's
just the way it is today but instead of
trying to be a modern man you know you
need to be a traditional man and that'll
that'll help you out in the long run
anyway feels loved the show if you're
going to go that mullet out you better
do it right that's just not a novelty
son the lifestyle dang that dude is
dropping hair knowledge a little bit of
follicle knowledgeable at the end it I
respect that and I appreciate that I
appreciate that call Billy and I just
think that that that's that's a it's a
keen attitude it's a keen attitude he's
been through it he said there was a
period of depression that you have to
make that choice how to do it to learn
to be the man you know you just need to
man up and that's something we all have
to remember you know is just to get up
each day and take care of our
responsibilities and especially in this
instance you know we get this idea that
how women are going to be the
breadwinners oh god now I'm you know
what am I gonna do my supposed to wear a
because look trust me for that first
year I might hit that depression you
know I might put on that muumuu and be
having chocolate snacks and having you
know men come to the house and you know
bring me cakes and bring me wine or
whatever you know fancy stuff I might go
get my hair done once every other week
you know and be living like that living
wild you know in this acting out through
some type of depression because I'm not
the breadwinner you know and wearing big
robes and big skirts and you know not
even doing the laundry and higher and
some little Filipino guy or Filipino
family to come and do the laundry but
when it comes down to it if I'm if
that's the right I'm going to take them
that's going to be a little that's going
to be a specific lonely cold road after
a couple of months after you've seen
every episode of Leave It to Beaver on
TV land or you ordered all the Jenny
Jones DVDs you know and watch rude you
get in there and comment on everything
you're going to lose a little bit of
steam there you're going to lose who you
are and he's saying we can still be a
man we can still be a man and I need to
hear it man I'm still growing up you
know and I'm afraid to grow up sometimes
and it's tough man it's not easy and I
guess no one's saying it is easy you
know but at least we got each other you
know we got other fathers stopping in
and pulling the guard for other fathers
that have passed away
we got stepfathers growing out mustaches
and giving some you know you know angry
feminists child that he doesn't even
agree with but he's paying for her
sandwiches and paying for her you know
special kits of her black panther you
know backpack patches and iron-on
patches and you know uh free Cuba
patches and stuff that she's buying in
the mail you know you got you got
fathers supporting children you got
fathers pulling their weight you know
and you got fathers out there who are
struggling dealing with addiction but
putting it away and getting back on the
horse and being a man and it's
interesting because that really doesn't
matter where the breads coming in there
it but it does matter you know where the
where the spine comes in you know where
the backbone shows up and some of these
men are doing that and I needed to hear
it man I appreciate it
I appreciate the calls this week man if
you guys have an issue or anything that
I can share if I can match you up with
somebody else who just would be able to
inspire us better than me I'm happy to
do that on this past weekend let me know
what you think about patreon hit the
Theo von comm store get you a got HAMP's
t-shirt cop that album that album is out
there man thirty pound bag of hamster
bone you can get it or the secondary
album which is my early work which is
it's called musket fire it's early
satire you can grab that out there as
well I'll see you guys in New York this
week and I'll see you in Nashville in a
few weeks
come out and show some love I promise
you I promise you that the live show is
good man I work really hard at my craft
and I love what I do and honestly man
there's some days where I think I could
be good at this you know and I feel good
today and I appreciate it man you guys
calling and keeping me company helped
this was honestly the best part of my
weekend man so you guys take take care
I'm going to listen to some celebrate
again on the way out this is from
Spencer growl and I'll put a link to to
their music you can check out and thank
you guys for everything I'll talk to you
guys soon be good to yourselves you know
because I bet you probably deserve it
you
hmm
[Music]
never play me
we sell a dog
that
the night Oh
Oh County men die
[Music]
all right yeah I'll be good out there
man
I love you guys see on the road see you
soon hit the hotline if you have
anything to say and I appreciate you
lemonade your thoughts you can check
this on iTunes you can watch it on
youtubes it will come out later on in
the day Thank You Man I needed you guys
today and I appreciate it thank you guys
very very much man damn it's hot as hell
in here
praise God boy look at that and look at
that pineapple hang out off the back of
this haircut God how long could this get
anything is possible